as well as Parliament has passed the
first of several laws that make up the
government's controversial judicial
overhaul that's despite Nationwide
protests against the changes to the
judicial system the plan would limit the
power of the Supreme Court critics say
it threatens democracy hundreds of
demonstrators have been blocking roads
in protest let's bring in our
correspondent Imran Khan he is joining
us live from West Jerusalem so tell us
about this law Iran that critics say is
tailor-made to protect prime minister
Netanyahu
well a lot of people are here are
calling it netanyahu's law basically the
law allows uh or disallows rather now
the Attorney General from declaring the
Prime Minister unfit for office why does
this apply uh to Benjamin yes you know
who well he has at least three court
cases going through they're winding
through the system at the moment so
regardless of whatever the result of
those court cases
he will continue to serve in office and
that's say the protesters is
undemocratic it was one of the key uh
things that the coalition government
wanted to push forward that's why this
has been passed before other parts of uh
the judicial reform uh bill it's a
series of reforms that's going to limit
the Supreme Court's power now because
this bill is passed we're likely to see
more people out on the street on
Saturday there is also a protest across
Israel 95 different locations across
Israel that's going on today but the big
protests there on Saturday and it's
likely to get more and more people out
on the street but the government is
passing these laws is holding firm and
it's holding firm because it does have a
very slim majority in Parliament and
that majority that Coalition is holding
firm because this is what the Coalition
wants it wants to to restrict the
Supreme Court and it seems to be working
so some form of this judicial Reform
Bill will likely pass will it pass
before Passover before Easter mid-april
we don't know that that's a key moment
in time so let's see what happens in the
coming days but absolutely this is going
to Galvanize the protest movement it'll
get more and more people out on the
streets and staying in the region but
looking at a different story and Ryan it
is the first day of the Muslim holy
month of Ramadan and Israel has imposed
restrictions or set rules rather on
worshipers entering the Al-Aqsa mosque
compound in Jerusalem
that helps you right it's something that
Israel does every single Ramadan it
takes it announces uh who can go and
pray within the Alexa most compound in
The Old City what they're saying is if
you're over the age of 55 yes that's
fine you can go between 55 and 45 if
you're male you need to apply for a
permit and if you're under 45 You're
simply not allowed to go you so people
won't be visiting from say the occupied
West Bank which they have been allowed
to do in previous years these
restrictions are placed all the time and
they get tougher and tougher as Conor
Ramadan goes on it's just a fact of
living under occupation now the Israeli
police say that they have learned from
clashes that took place when they placed
restrictions in 2020 that those clashes
were almost every single night in
Damascus gay in occupied East Jerusalem
and they eventually led to the war on
Gaza the 11-day war that took place in
May so uh the the police say yes we have
learned we are going to allow people to
to go to the mosque we're not going to
use heavy-handed security tactics that
is something that the police the guy in
charge of the police effectively this
national security minister Minister item
doesn't want he wants a hard line so
there's this disconnect now between what
other police are saying publicly and
what the national security minister
wants and that is being seen as a
Flashpoint
Imran thank you very much for that that
is Imran Khan joining us live from West
Jerusalem